so he thought his doctor was a jerk
until his heart no longer worked
comedian and actor Bob Odenkirk has been
kicking around show business for over 30
years he started as a writer on SNL he
was really funny on the underrated Ben
Stiller show he co-created the brilliant
sketch comedy Mr Show and now most
people know him as the CD attorney Saul
Goodman on Better Call Saul good things
are good thing there's no lawyer that's
sleazy in real life am I right
he also does a lot of charity work for
the underprivileged
I knew the audience would not know who
David Cross is
but I left it in there anyway because I
don't care a few years ago Odenkirk had
a heart attack and almost died while
filming the final season of his series
true Better Call Saul became better call
9-1-1 it's a fate I wouldn't wish on any
actors unless they try to bring back
According to Jim
Odin Kirk survived thank goodness and
recently he went on a podcast and looked
back on his heart attack saying this
near-death experience could have been
prevented if he had only listened to his
doctor
so why didn't he listen
my doctor was a conservative he got
crankier and crankier the older he got I
hated this side of him that I only
learned over time he said you need to
start taking statins right now and I
said well I don't know I don't have
heart disease in my family he goes just
take them and I had a heart attack and I
think the first doctor was right the
cranky conservative Jack was right
because he was a God good doctor
his political point of view doesn't have
anything to do with his ability to judge
your health and your health choices and
needs well that's well said that's why I
never questioned my liberal doctor when
he gives me a mammogram
because Bob's an honest guy kudos to him
he didn't need to say this in public but
he wanted everybody to know the tough
lesson he learned I'm sure all his
Showbiz friends deserted him like he was
Jerry Nadler at a nudist colony
I know think about that
but America needs more of that these
days well that and handsome brilliant
people like me to point it out we need
to start seeing each other as human
beings again not not just Pawns of two
opposing political parties our lives are
more important than some dumb agenda and
someone should tell that to those Harry
heifers at The View
we're people not talking points except
cat she's more of a warning label
but what if Odin Kirk had a doctor with
a much different world view like I don't
know maybe this
the upside uh she can check your
prostate without her hands
I know
but imagine if he had a far left Doctor
Who had told him not to do anything to
prevent heart disease because you know
there are too many humans on the planet
already because he's an old white guy
who doesn't have the common decency to
identify as an old white woman
because politics Will indeed matter if
say you have a woke Doctor Who's only
concerned with Equity someone who lets
you die untreated to raise the rates of
cancer among your group identity to
match those of another quote
marginalized group that's the logic
sorry you're gonna die bill but enjoy
your last few months knowing you
contributed to an equitable Society
here's an envelope for BLM when you make
out your will
you can imagine how bad things would get
if all those jobs you rely on to make
your life better were filled with woke
Knuckleheads the woke mechanic would say
instead of an oil change I converted
your car to solar power it only works
when it's sunny out that'll be 80 grand
or how about a woke police officer can I
see some ID we add reports there are
people over the age of 18 at this drag
show or how about the woke teacher
wait those are everywhere
and how is that working out our students
are
it's as if education is replacing
knowledge with grievance and team locker
rooms with I'll show you mine if you
show me yours
now let's look at it from the opposite
perspective how many worksters have
refused good advice because the experts
had the wrong politics sure I could have
changed my oil when that check engine
light came on four months ago if I
supported poisoning Mother Earth with
fossil fuels also can you give me a ride
home
you know doc I'm against the use of all
petroleum products including Plastics so
you'll need if you you'll need to do
that prostate exam on me wearing a
renewable wool glove
wasting all that water just because my
home's on fire now I'm really glad I
glued myself to that fire hydrant
sure I could describe the man who beat
and robbed me but you'd probably run
straight to the cops let's just say he's
a really dark-skinned white male
if all this sounds crazy consider that
we now have doctors in America cutting
off little boys genitals because they
play with Barbies and somebody told them
they're actually girls thank God these
doctors weren't around when I was a kid
I went trick-or-treating as a kid
dressed like Dorothy Hamill three years
in a row
I got 27 sticker bars and three gold
medals
doctors are capable of being as
blinkered and unethical as anybody else
plus they can't dance
nothing
[Music]
for years now we've heard the refrain
that's between me and my doctor I've
said it many times myself when I'm asked
what I'm doing at the gynecologist
even medicine is getting weird the
American Medical Association is pushing
something awful called Health Equity to
fight narratives grounded in white
supremacy evil narratives that favor
meritocracy and individualism
meaning they prefer to treat you as one
person belonging to a group that
oppresses rather than a person with
chest pain but maybe you deserve to be
sick that mole is malignant but so are
you
so why would you allow your medical
decisions to be swayed by any outside
consideration you'd never say that's
between me my doctor and the Department
of Motor Vehicles or would you if you'd
rather have a heart attack than listen
to a republican maybe the problem isn't
the Republicans
sure you went completely blind now but
at least you didn't let Dr Rand Paul an
ophthalmologist tell you what to do
the moral of the story listen to the
person who's telling you a hard truth
even if you don't like them and if you
insist on being woke all the time take
it up with your anesthesiologist I'm
Steve Doocy I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis